pour twitter pour à la question point de
vue l'autre question
elle n'est pas sur twitter elle est sur
le site du figaro c'est faut-il
sanctionner les grévistes qui coupe le
courant c'est une info à lire également
sur le site du figaro le frère martin a
bien cru qu'il verrait sa dernière heure
ce dominicain de 91 ans a eu son
assistance respiratoire coupé pendant
trois quarts d'heure hier en cause et
bien précisément des coupures
d'électricité provoquées par des agents
de la cgt du réseau de transport a
explicité alors c'était pas de l'anti
cléricalisme
c'était simplement la conséquence d'un
mouvement qui concernait cette ville de
lyon également la gironde est également
le vieux nice quatre vingt dix mille
foyers au moins qui ont été privés
d'électricité touchés selon rte
voici l'explication qui était donné ce
matin par le secrétaire général de la
cgt philippe martinez ceux qui sont dans
le sud-ouest dans les landes aujourd'hui
avec les inondations bravo on leur dit
bravo faut venir on leur dit faut venir
on n'a pas besoin de leur dire faut
venir ils viennent volontairement mais
on leur dit en même temps on va vous
pétez votre statut on va voir remettre
en cause au vos retraites et en plus on
casse votre boîte on peut flatter les
usagers et je vous dis ces coupures sont
ciblés mais cracher cracher sur le
service public de l'énergie
vous comprenez que c'est énervant mais
non mais et je pense qu'un certain
nombre de gens du gouvernement ferait
mieux de la fermer de la ferme est
plutôt que de provoquer ces agents qui
sont au service du public
et cet après midi le secrétaire général
de la cgt en a remis une couche à la
sortie de matignon
quand madame bornes se permet de faire
passer une vidéo sur le réseau intranet
d'edf
grdf de rte d'aînés 10 pour expliquer
pourquoi sa réforme est bonne la veille
d'une journée de mobilisation alors ça 2
conséquence ça augmente le taux de
grévistes mais ça énerve les grévistes
alors s'énerve également elisabeth
bornes qui a exprimé son coup ce matin
sur l'antenne de france inter qui s'est
passé est grave
voyez quand on a des dizaines de
milliers de foyers qui ont été privés
d'électricité
cinquante mille en gironde 40000 à lyon
et puis à lyon 5 cliniques et puis moi
je demande aussi à philippe martinez de
clarifier sa position sur ce sujet je
l'entends dire qu'on coupe les
entreprises du cac 40 les préfectures
des centres commerciaux
c'est déjà assez discutable mais là je
le redis des cliniques des stations de
métro des casernes de pompiers et puis
des milliers de français comme vous et
moi qui se retrouvent privés
d'électricité alors pour être complet
philippe martinez cet après midi à
matignon a dit qu' il m'appelait les
agents de la cgt à amplifier le
mouvement mais cette fois ci à rendre
rendre l'électricité à remettre
l'électricité chez ceux qui l'ont coupé
du fait qu'ils ne payent plus leurs
factures ou bien à continuer à pratiquer
la politique des taux bas ça c'est plus
malin non
la question de la sanction des grévistes
qui se dissimulent leur droit de grève
pour couper l'électricité c'est une
question aussi un peu juridique car
excusez moi mais alors la règle c'est
qu'on peut pas licencier quelqu'un pour
avoir fait la grève sauf si il est il a
excédé le droit grève pour accomplir des
actes avec une intention de nuire et le
courant et mettre des gens en danger je
pense qu'on n'est pas très très loin de
l'intention de nuire qui excède
notablement ce que l'on peut tolérer
d'un gréviste on peut tolérer une
absence on peut tolérer une
manifestation on peut tolérer un
tractage
mais on ne peut pas tolérer un sabotage
on peut pas tolérer des piquets de grève
on peut pas tolérer une coupure de
courant la bataille juridique s'est elle
concerne les gens qui ont procédé à ces
coupures ou bien le concerne également
les entreprises auxquelles ils
appartiennent bel concerne les 2 mai
mais surtout les agents eux-mêmes qui se
sont mis en dehors et de délégations du
programme ici on sent que c'est
disciplinairement eh bien ils pourront
contester cette sanction mais la
jurisprudence est quand même assez
stricte sur ce qui relève du droit de
grève et qui interdit à l'employeur
toute sanction de type licenciements ou
même mis à pied ou voilà toute sanction
de droit du travail mais je crois quand
même que couper l'électricité en mettant
ainsi en danger les clients d'une
entreprise me paraît excédé les limites
du droit de grève faut-il sanctionner
les grévistes qui coupe le courant c'est
la question qu'on pose sur le site du
figaro il ya beaucoup moins déjà qui a
voté il ya plus de quarante mille
votants et c'est pour l'instant un oui
franc et massif
alors il ya des commentaires kriss kross
avant de rejoindre
le commentaire de cette émission avait
déjà commenté sous cette question posée
par le site du figaro qui nous disait il
faut amplifier le mouvement en coupant
maximum l'électricité des groupes du cac
40 et même de la bourse de paris
euronext à courbevoie rima me dit
maintenant d'aller couper à l'elysée
al'inverse cet autre internaute qui nous
dit faire grève c'est ne pas travailler
couper le courant et du vandalisme
passible des tribunaux et claudie stomie
je soutiens les grèves mais pas les
coupures et vous mon chat avec sans moi
je suis un observateur non bien sûr
qu'il faut pas enfreindre la loi et le
gouvernement d'ailleurs plutôt que faire
des coups de mentos il ya des actions en
justice a déclenché bien qu'il le qu'il
le fasse après je pense que dans ce
genre de mouvement il ya aussi une
bataille une bataille symbolique de
l'opinion on voit bien que martinez y
fait un peu marche arrière puisque c'est
plus sympathique effectivement de
rétablir le courant à ceux qui ne vont
pas te payer serait d'après vers ce côté
donc voilà il ya une bataille de
l'opinion avec le gouvernement peut-être
avait marqué un point parce que là la
cgt et et josh justement hors cadre
époux et c'était une action qui n'était
pas très sympathique finalement martinez
reviendra en arrière
voilà on verra à la fin comment comment
bascule au pineau moi je crois plutôt
qu'il va y avoir que des paires dont
sept dans cette histoire je pense que la
cgt fait sont enfin les syndicats font
leur baroud d'honneur on voit bien
qu'ils sont quand même démonétisé depuis
quelques années on l'a vu au moment du
mouvement des gels et josé voir côté
d'ailleurs de recueillir près de l'autre
côté on a aussi un gouvernement
technocratique assez des mots des 10 et
qui va faire une révolte
une réforme qui plaira peut-être à 20%
de la population mais qui laisse à
malaise diffus un sentiment de fracture
entre les élites et les classes
populaires fait regarde d'un autre côté
vous voilà philippe martinez s'est
exprimé cet après midi on n'en fait pas
un peu un peu trop loin non pas du tout
au contraire je pense qu'on ne fait pas
assez
moi je trouve et isabelle plante assez
gentil quand elle se contente de dire
que ces actions sont discutables il
s'agit là d' action criminelle
on a quand même la féra une espèce de
dérive mafieuse du droit de grève
comment réagiriez-vous si moi je venais
chez vous pour saboter votre appartement
ou votre maison au motif que je ne suis
pas content avec telle ou telle réforme
vous masse ignoré en justice tout de
suite je vous le garantis non mais c'est
quelque chose qui est quand même assez
assez tristes parce que une économie de
marché à un pays comme la france a
besoin d'un syndicalisme fort
représentatif authentique légitime pour
contribuer à la régulation pacifique des
rapports sociaux et c'est dans cet
esprit-là que damman les réformateurs
libéraux du rôle durant le second empire
on abolit le délit de coalition avec la
loi olivier donc il ya une volonté il ya
là une aspiration légitime à un
syndicalisme représentatif qui
contribuent à réguler les rapports
sociaux dans ce pays
sauf que la cgt n'est pas du tout dans
ce paradigme là c'est un c'est un
syndicat qui est radicale qui comme on
dire applique un syndicalisme de terreur
et de combat pour par pure
anticapitalisme et que je ne suis pas
sûr que cette démarche lui lui comédien
lui lui du sceau favorable dans
l'opinion publique le construit à partir
une balance qui va justement ça c'est
intéressant donc ça ce que en tout cas
vos propos plaisent à nathan qui lisent
bien ce fergane décidément à la verse
[Musique]
babineau dit ils peuvent bloquer les
transports ils peuvent aussi coupé
l'électricité oui c'est une
démonstration de force 1 orange ans
pardon de vous poser la question comme
ça mais s'il n'y a pas d'action coup
d'éclat comme ça on risque
je trouve intéressant de faire le
parallèle avec les transports parce que
mon avis il faut le faire c'est à dire
que parler d'actions criminelles ou de
terreur dans le cas de la cgt ça me
paraît quand même un peu abusif que
philippe martinez soit dans une position
de provocation qui soit radical qui soit
pas prêt à discuter c'est assez clair
quand il justifie ses actions par le
fait que les grévistes sont en colère
c'est pas tenable comme argument la
colère sociale elle est là c'est pour ça
qu'il ya un droit de grève c'est pour ça
qu'il ya d'autres moyens d'action légaux
donc sa position n'est pas tenable que
des gens soient sanctionnés que
l'entreprise soit sanctionné moi ça ne
me scandalise pas ce qui est intéressant
effectivement c'est ce qui se joue par
rapport à l'opinion
et là je veux dire des deux côtés c'est
quand même un peu basique qu'il faut les
français sont quand même pas binaire à
ce point c'est à dire philippe martinez
qui vous dis moi je suis en colère donc
j'ai tous les droits
eh bien non elisabeth bornes qui essaye
de nous faire croire que en fait les
syndicalistes sont nos ennemis
c'est un peu basique et binaire aussi et
donc à je crois qu'il faut faire
attention parce que sur les transports
c'est évident que les gens sont très
empêché par tout ça c'est évident que
tout le monde trouve la situation
difficile et pénible c'est évident aussi
quand on passe du temps un peu devant
les arrêts de bus où les gens sont
passés et c'est que pour l'instant la
colère la colère n'est pas tournée vers
les grévistes elle est tournée vers le
gouvernement donc il faut faire
attention c'est à dire que s'il
suffisait de dire ils vous ont pris en
otage donc maintenant le gouvernement va
faire alliance avec l'opinion contre les
syndicats je pense qu' un jeu très
dangereux précisément parce qu'on a
besoin d'instances représentatives c'est
un jeu très dangereux de vouloir
marginaliser les syndicats encore
davantage que ce qu'ils sont déjà
aujourd'hui dans notre pays c'est à dire
que le pas lundi cas qui sont prêts à
travailler malgré un moment sur soi
aussi
le gouvernement essaye de parler
directement à l'opinion en passant par
dessus la tête des syndicats et de tous
les corps intermédiaires comme il fait
depuis le départ et c'est un jeu très
dangereux d'augmenter restera plus que
le peuple face aux élites
mais le problème c'est que c'est comme
intermédiaire de revenus le problème
c'est que c'est comme intermédiaire ne
représente rien déjà aujourd'hui c'est à
dire que je pars appelé le tout indiquée
sur son des français il autour de 10% je
crois si ma mémoire est bonne de tête
donc on a déjà des organisations qui
prétendent parler au nom d'une volonté
générale qui ne sont absolument pas
légitime aaa à incarner et je crains
qu'ils n'ont pas besoin du gouvernement
pour se marginaliser et de couper le
courant juste parce qu'on n'est pas
d'accord avec une réforme
encore une fois c'est quelque chose qui
a défendu ce point de vue en tous les
cas vos points de vue sont intéressants
ils sont assez assez divergents sur
cette question bertrand perrier il ya
une forme d'hystérie za sion il ya une
forme d'hystérie cette série starisation
en fait dans dans le dans le débat on
est dans le money time de la grève on
voit bien que là on est vraiment dans
une période de très grande tension avant
les fêtes
ils essayent de pousser leur avantage y
compris par des actes illégaux et on
voit bien que il ya une façon d'essayer
de montrer ses muscles avant le
démarrage réel de négociations et les
fêtes de noël qui seront vraiment pour
moi le vraiment le la date butoir juste
mentionné dans le mouvement et dans tout
ce qui se passe dans le pays la sur la
réforme des retraites il n'y a pas
seulement les syndicats il ya aussi tous
les gens qui sont pas syndiqués et qui
regarde ce qui se passe avec inquiétude
et qui pour l'instant en tout cas n'ont
pas déclaré massivement qu'ils étaient
du côté du gouvernement et pas des
syndicats portent tous les cas de choses
et deux choses contradictoires
d'ailleurs il ya un soutien au mouvement
il ya un soutien à la réforme et il ya
un soutien notamment même à l'idée d'un
de l'âge pivot sont assez largement à
l'idée d'une réforme qu'elle est
nécessaire sont de sortie
en tous les cas les indicateurs sans se
prononcer sur le fond mais des
indicateurs montrent que le nombre de
français qui pensent que le gouvernement
ira jusqu'au bout
augmente donc est d'habitude les
spécialistes politologues disent en tout
cas que c'est le facteur déterminant
dans la bataille de l'opinion
sauf que vous formulez très bien les
choses on a les deux on a le soutien et
voilà non mais on a dû on a le soutien à
la réforme moi je trouve que ça a fait
du chemin dans la tête des gens depuis
1995 il me semble que les gens sont
acquis à la nécessité de faire une
réforme et qu'ils étaient prêts à
l'accepter c'est pour ça que sur le plan
de la communication politique moi je dis
mais pourquoi allait gâcher une
possibilité de trouver un consensus sur
un dossier important comme celui là en
voulant passer outre la négociation avec
les syndicats en tout cas les syndicats
réformistes
alors l ambiguïté dans le terme de
réformes depuis longtemps qui a un terme
positif et les droits des enfants c'est
trente dernières années ont été des
réformes qu'on le veuille ou non
régressive je ne dis pas que c'était
pâques ont abordé un tracé de les faire
ou pas le sujet le sujet avait mixé les
enfermer les sanctions à l'encontre les
autres sanctions éventuellement les
comptes à l'encontre de ceux à qui on
coupe et procéder aux coupures
d'électricité
les coupures de courant sont illégales
me semble-t-il nous dit romain donc
sanctions ça paraît logique
où est l'état de droit la citoyens me
dise et les agents et les dix était
fonctionnaire se serait révocation pour
sabotage vous confirmez bertrand ce la
destruction de l'audi travail mais oui
il sanctions oui et c'est vieux déjà en
on m'a tout coupé dit chris kraus et
bien
on rappellera la question qui est posée
sur le site du figaro faut-il
sanctionner les grévistes qui coupe le
courant et pour l'instant c'est comme
aurait dit le général de gaulle un oui
franc et massif
on va passer de l'autre côté de
l'atlantique et on va aller aux états
unis